Humans have been trying to figure out how traits are inherited
in all their peculiar ways since the beginning of recorded history.
>> Listen. I think we can even hear the eternal argument happening now.
>> You gotta be kidding me. Pea plants. I can explain blended
traits, but you think what works for pea plants works for humans?
>> My method explains all the traits
that yours can't, even those that appear to
skip generations. After the rules of heredity
are true for all living things. From pea
plants to humans.
>> No, you guys are forgetting about the really complex
behavioral traits that play a big part in the environment.
>>
[CROSSTALK]
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
>> guys, there's no need to yell at each other. I'm sure this is something
we can settle with the friendly demonstration. Hippocrates
Why don't we go with your idea first?